le front national se met en ordre de
marche dans les yvelines
à deux mois du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle est une
conférence pour présenter la stratégie
du parti est organisée ce mercredi 22
février à versailles parmi les partisans
jenlain la capelle membres du conseil
stratégique de la campagne du fn et
conseiller régional d'île de france
nous avons tout simplement mis en place
une équipe tournée marine 2007 nous
avons décidé en six semaines de visiter
les 95 fédérations françaises évidemment
les y vivront leur contribution rossi et
nous sommes là pour convaincre les
quelques hésitant encore où les quelques
électeurs volatile
objectif annoncé par le front national
dans les yvelines 21% premier tour de la
présidentielle un score largement
envisageable selon les partisans à
chaque élection on a progressé on est
parti de lui de 8 % aux régionales 2010
par exemple pour arriver à 20% 19 ans
120% au départemental et régional
donc on peut dire fait espérer à la
présidentielle ça se déroule de la même
façon au même moment l'enquêté sur les
emplois fictifs présumés au parlement
européen a pris une nouvelle tournure
avec la mise en examen de catherine
grise et proche collaboratrice de marine
le pen et va la faire cesser la
coopération politique
les gens font la différence entre les
affaires qui ont des contenus les
affaires qui n'ont pas contenus qui sont
du registre de l'opération politique
donc je leur fais totalement confiance
est d'ailleurs en voie de sondage il ya
aucun affrontement ce qui veut bien dire
que c'est lisse et que ça roule
une affaire qui ne devrait pas perturber
l'organisation du grand meeting parisien
le 17 avril prochain le seul rendez-vous
en ile de france la fédération des
yvelines il participera en envoyant une
délégation